wenn es heute Abend bei ihnen klingelt
dann ist es sehr wahrscheinlich dass ein
paar Hexen oder Vampire vor ihrer Tür
stehen und Süßes oder Saures rufen denn
sehr wie sie schon sicher annehmen
können es ist Halloween das Gruselfest
das in den USA groß gefeiert wird und
auch hier zu Lande immer beliebter wird
in den vergangenen Jahren gab es
allerdings eine Vielzahl von
Zwischenfällen an diesem Tag und darüber
spreche ich jetzt mit Tim Hendrik Walter
er ist Fachanwalt für Familienrecht und
der jüngeren Generation bei Youtube
Instagram und tik tok als Herr Anwalt
bekannt einen schönen guten Morgen
tatsächlich ist Halloween für die
Polizei einen schönen guten Morgen ein
für die Polizei ist Halloween ein sehr
arbeitsintensiver Tag denn gerne werden
auch mal Streiche gespielt was sind denn
typische Halloween vergehen
also das fängt meistens schon bei der
Verkleidung an die Kostüme werden ja
immer aufwendiger und viele Leute neigen
dazu und wissen das gar nicht dass wenn
sie sogenannte Anstands Anscheinswaffen
benutzen dass das ein Riesenproblem ist
weil die Polizei häufig nicht
unterscheiden kann naja liegt jetzt eine
echte Waffe vor oder ist das nur eine
Attrappe und da bitte aufpassen also
wenn Waffen wirklich täuschend echt
aussehen oder Attrappen täuschend echt
wie Waffen aussehen da ein Auge drauf
haben das ist nach dem Waffengesetz
verboten beispielsweise also
spielpistole zum Beispiel oder Pfeil und
Bogen ab welchem Alter sind ja vor allem
Kinder die da von Tür zu Tür gehen ab
welchem Alter ist man denn überhaupt
haftbar für solche Dinge
also Kinder unter 14 Jahre können sich
grundsätzlich erstmal nicht strafbar
machen wenn die Kinder natürlich
irgendwelche Streiche machen
beispielsweise mit Eiern auf Autos
werfen was durchaus ein Schaden
verursachen kann dann kommt es
tatsächlich auf das Alter aber vor allen
Dingen auf die Einsichtsfähigkeit des
Kindes an das Kind kann also durchaus
auch schon selber haftbar sein manchmal
haften aber auch die Eltern wenn sie
ihre Aufsichtspflicht verletzen
Sachbeschädigung ist klar was ist denn
wenn sich jemand so sehr erschreckt dass
er zum Beispiel hinfällt sich stößt also
Personenschaden was passiert da
genau auch da kann man sollte man
aufpassen ich kann Leute auch mal
erschrecken ich sollte mich aber immer
vergewissern in welcher Situation bin
ich gerade wenn das mir völlig fremde
Leute sind sollte ich aufpassen wenn
beispielsweise ein älterer Mann an einer
viel befahrenen Straße steht und ich
gehe von hinten an und erschrecke ihn
und er läuft auf die Straße ja dann
hätte man möglicherweise damit rechnen
können dass das passiert also immer
gucken wo befinde ich mich gerade wer
ist die andere Person und dann kommt man
eigentlich ganz gut durch Halloween
viele Eltern gehen ja mit ihren Kindern
mit worauf sollten die achten
die Eltern sollten vor allen Dingen
darauf achten dass die Kinder eben keine
Straftaten begehen also beispielsweise
keiner Eier auf Autos werfen generell
nicht benutzen was bleibende Schäden
hinter ist wenn man mal bei einem
Bekannten Nachbarn deren Spaß versteht
mit Zahnpasta unter der Türklinke
irgendwie eine Linie zieht dann kann man
das durchaus machen weil das ist leicht
abwaschbar und man sollte vielleicht
auch darauf achten was die Kinder
hinterher auch für Bonbons bekommen da
kann ja mal irgendwie was drin sein eine
ältere Dame meint naja das Kind kann
ruhig hier so ein Cognac Trüffel nehmen
oder so dann mal besser vielleicht drauf
gucken was haben die Kinder überhaupt
mit nach Hause gebracht
heißt ich kann mich haftbar machen wenn
ich den Kindern Süßigkeiten gebe die
vielleicht nicht mehr gut sind oder
Alkohol beinhalten
also da sollte man natürlich wenn man
den Kindern irgendwas gibt sollte man
auch darauf achten dass es sich um
Süßigkeiten für Kinder oder Jugendliche
handelt und dass da kein Alkohol drin
ist also das bitte nicht auf Vorrat
legen
wie lange dürfen denn Kinder überhaupt
abends draußen bleiben
also es gibt keine gesetzliche Regelung
wie lange Kinder draußen bleiben dürfen
bei Kinos oder Gaststätten ist ein
bisschen was anderes an Halloween
einfach draußen rumspazieren können Sie
theoretisch solange wie sie möchten das
ist Aufgabe der Eltern das zu begrenzen
natürlich sollte jetzt ein
Siebenjähriger vielleicht um 1 Uhr nicht
mehr draußen sein da kann es dann auch
mal sein dass die Polizei da mal fragt
hey wo kommst du denn her und den dann
nach Hause fährt vielen Dank Tim Hendrik
Walter für diese Einschätzung danke für
das Gespräch
danke schön